[Music]
I like the way you kiss
me I like the
way I like the way you kiss me I can
tell you miss me I can tell it is is is
is I'm trying to be romantic I hit it
from the back just so you don't get ATT
tach I like the way you kiss me I can
tell you miss me I can tell it this this
this I'm trying to be romantic I hit it
from the back just so you don't get
test you B my lip just feel the taste
you're on your knees I'm on the case you
take the heat with such Grace you say
don't but he St so just scared I'll let
you
down stick around and you'll find
out don't you want to make me
proud cuz I'm so proud baby I'm so proud
of you I like the way you kiss me I can
tell you listen me I can tell it this
this this this I'm trying to be romantic
I hit it from the back just so you don't
get
attach I like the way you kiss me I can
tell you miss me I can tell it this this
this this I'm trying to be romantic I
hit it from the back just so you don't
get it tou go stress you out can I help
you out cuz I turn you on when I turn
you around can we make a see you make it
loud cuz I'm so proud I'm so proud of
you I like the way you P me I can tell
you I can tell it this this this this
not trying to be romantic I hit it from
the back just so you don't give the test
this I like the way you kiss me I can
tell you miss me I can tell it this this
this this you're trying to be romantic I
hit it from the back just so you don't
test I kiss
me I like the way
hey there friend thanks so much for
watching this video If You dug those pop
and flow POI that I was using hey you
can get a discount on them if you use my
special promo code Drex Factor
0522 again that is drexfactor
2024 over on the flow toys website
that'll get you 10% off pop and flow poy
or any other prop in the online store
thank you so much to flow toys for
sponsoring this video and making it
possible for me to share flow sessions
like this one with you all speaking of
thank yous though I got to give a shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Tera light toys spinballs and Ultra PO
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they are doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and of course speci thanks to
the non- bus friend of the channel That
is Becca beckin thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission finally this video would not be
possible nor any of the videos on my
channel without the support of my
awesome patreon subscribers in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my work if you out there are
not currently supporter but you'd like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor po and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be supporting me in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out more of my flow
videos I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks again for watching make sure to
get out and flow today yourselves and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace